The cosmos the universe is an idea, a place,
a concept that has been haunting the human mind for literally thousands and
thousands of years from time and Memorial.
Our species has been strongly interested in and influenced by the stars.
Just think about it for one moment with the history of Meritain dread have been
possible without the astrolabe with the development of agriculture and medieval
Europe have been possible ever tangent had not been paid to do the cosmos.
Something that helped our ancestors knew when the time was right for each stage
of cultivation. And of course,
beyond studying the universe for such practical means we cannot forget or even
deny that the stars have also had a strong influence and enormous attraction,
an amazing power to give flight to our fantasy and imagination all the way back
in the second century and his work, a true story right there.
[inaudible] fantasize about the idea of reaching the stars of seeing extra
terrestrial worlds,
and even imagined Wars between the monarchs of other planets.
And he was not the only one since then many others like Siriano to bear Jack
Daniel, the, and of course, Jules Verne.
They continued to fantasize about flying to destined alien worlds,
but don't worry. Don't panic.
This video is not about the history of astronomy or science fair
On the 20th of December, 2019, president Donald J.
Trump signed as this customer in the defense budget for the following year.
However, in the act S one seven nine zero,
there was something that was far from normal. You see, on that day,
Andrews air force base,
president Donald Trump created the U S S F the United States space force.
And the question is, was this more than just a headline?
Has there ever been anything like this before in the United States,
are there plans to militarize space with weapons, orbiting the earth?
Are we about to have all of our Saifai fantasies come true? Well,
today we will answer all of those questions,
but first we need to look at some history.
The race for space domination.
The 1950s, the cold war two Titans at odds,
a struggle between communism and capitalism,
the Soviet union versus the United States. You could say,
but the starting gun that marked the beginning of the space race was fired by
the Soviet union. On the 4th of October, 1957. On that day,
the split Nick one satellite was put into orbit. And as you can imagine,
over in the land of rock and roll Apple pie and hamburgers,
the launch of Sputnik left a pretty bad taste in the mouth.
It was totally unexpected. And to top it all off,
it wasn't the only one less than a month later,
the USSR was launching its Sputnik too,
sadly famous for launching the poor little dog Laika as a crew member.
Let's all take a moment. It's just so sad.
The fact that as though it wasn't until the following year in 1958,
that the Americans were finally able to move their plane piece from the starting
box. And this particular risks, the Denso the launch of their first satellite,
the Explorer one.
Blitz.
Although the Americans got their act together with their first satellite and the
creation of NASA in 1959 and 1961, the Soviets once again,
left the world at speechless on April 12th of that year,
a young Eureka garden became the first person to navigate and space upon his
return. He was received as a true international superhero,
just a few weeks later, the American Alan Shepard followed him,
but of course they had already won that much and Moscow.
And the fact is during the first part of the space race,
the Soviet union was clearly ahead.
The USSR managed to successfully conclude the mission after meshing,
abandoning the Earth's orbit landing on the moon. Yes.
Landing on the moon and even undertaking the first mission to Venus.
They seemed unstoppable. Listen up.
Mine was the first soft landing mission on the moon.
The Soviet spacecraft rived three years before the first human stepped out on
the surface.
It was part of a long range Soviet union program to photograph and learn more
about the moon space.com.
Hold on just one moment, because on the 25th of May in 1961,
something happened that would forever change the position of these counters.
On the particular game board, we're talking about.
Nothing.
John F. Kennedy gave a speech to the U S Congress.
And when she sets a new national priority to make a man clearly an American man
walk on the moon and returned home safely,
they had to achieve this before the end of the 1960s. And as we often say,
no sooner said than done on the 20th of July in 1969,
the United States may be somewhat unique entry and to history on that day,
Neil Armstrong stepped onto the moon marking a giant leap from forward.
Okay.
You're probably thinking at this point, you're thinking, all right, grant,
but these are all things that we know, but this is visual politic.
Our role is to try and look beyond and figure out what, wait,
what role and what political influence this kind of space race had.
And that is exactly what we're going to do. And the first thing,
the first key to understanding this whole story is to take a look at the main
differences that existed between the Soviet and the American space programs for
decades.
Geez.
You see,
although the Soviet union militarized its space race from very early on,
let's say that this was something that the Americans did not consider at first,
at least not in the same terms.
Let me explain president Eisenhower himself general, Dwight D Eisenhower,
Ike to his friends wrote to Bulgarian the president of the USSR council of
ministers, and to Khrushchev his Soviet counterpart,
a series of letters in 1957 in 1958, to convince them to make the space mission,
a project of scientific cooperation between the two countries,
rather than a race. Of course he failed still.
The Americans did not throw in the toe soon after they created NASA and the same
spirit as a completely civilian, an independent agency. And not only that,
thanks to the space act of 1958,
American scientists had a lot of freedom to carry out the research on space.
This was very different from the USSR who space measuring was tightly controlled
by the ministry of general machine building of the USSR,
the ministry answering to the USS,
our military industrial commission of the USSR council of ministers,
who we go through, all those acronyms,
However, JFK, there's another acronym he tried again.
And the wake of Eisenhower.
JFK also tried to turn the space race into a space of Dante and cooperation with
his then arch enemy of the hammer. And second, and fact,
and his first speech as president, he uttered these words.
Seek to invoke the wonders of science instead of its parents.
Again, explore the thought.
But my friends, Chris, Jeff,
once again turned a deaf ear that selected hearing continued up until 1962,
when the United States managed to put John Glenn into orbit. At that point,
the Soviets finally began to test the ground for possible space cooperation with
the Americans. And of course, Massa took up the gauntlet instantly.
The two great art enemies of the team reached an unprecedented agreement and
agreement by which the undertook to share among other things, weather forecasts.
And yes, yes. I know it might seem insignificant,
but think about what that meant symbolically not to mention it was against the
backdrop of the almost paranoid atmosphere of secrecy and the USSR.
So don't go thinking that this was a piece of cake because it was fun.
It.
Of the Soviet union themselves. For example, Mr.
[inaudible] president of the Academy of sciences did not see why on earth.
They had to share their findings with the enemy,
even though it was only about meteorological data,
but of course the context was terrible. Look at the case of coldish himself,
the president of the Academy of sciences checkup.
Academician coldish himself was the subject of paranoid secrecy for many
years. Kel dishes name was a state secret.
He was known only as the anonymous chief theorist of cosmetics rolled
saga, Dave Russian expert in plasma physics,
and a former director of the space research Institute of the USSR cademy of
sciences.
Seriously,
that kind of makes Cal there's something like the Voldemort of the USSR.
And as if that mistrust wasn't enough,
then Brezhnev came to the Kremlin and pulled the handbrake. And once again,
on all that, talking to the Americans.
Yeah.
I've had previously been the commissioner of all military industry issues before
entering the Politburo. And my friends,
Leonid Leonid was satin that the USSR had a clear advantage and that there was
no point in collaborating with the Americans.
Why help them if they could beat them, but it turns out he was wrong.
Brezhnev had made a huge mistake. Why? Because just a few years later,
the next administration would overtake them with new Armstrong walking on the
moon and putting his little American flag on the surface of our closest heavenly
body. So with Armstrong's let those straw on the moon,
the moon and the Kremlin was no longer at the scene.
And then suddenly plot twist because it's here,
the Gregory Peck and gene Hackman appeared on the scene and yes, no, seriously,
I have not gone mental. I am being genuine. It turns out that in 1970,
a top level meeting between the Soviet and American scientists,
the Americans came up with something that would leave the Russian scientists
very, very low
Phillip handler. Then president of the United States Academy of sciences,
starting talking to kale dish,
the chief scientist of the USSR about a film that had been released in
Hollywood.
The film marooned told the story of three American astronauts who were lost in
space and who were ultimately rescued by Soviet cosmonauts.
And let's just say that those raised in the land of the hammer and sickle had a
little bit of trouble grasping all this. I mean, why,
why was Hollywood seeming to create Soviet propaganda?
What was up with that and take notes because handler actually managed to
convince them that in the face of a catastrophic situation,
like the one presented in the film,
it would be necessary to have compatible systems in order to work together.
And what's even more surprising is they came to an agreement and not just a
symbolic one,
but a historical agreement and the middle of the cold war with both
countries, keeping their fingers poised on the nuclear button.
These two great enemies smoke to the peace pipe just long enough to develop the
Apollo Soyuz collaboration project. That is impressive.
New possibilities are opening up for fruitful
development of scientific cooperation between countries and the peoples in the
interest of peace and progress of all of humanity
learned. But as still.
However, my friends on the 20th of January, 1981,
the United States space strategy would take a 180 degree turn because my friends
on that day, a new man arrived at the white house. Listen to this.
Star Wars.
On the 20th of January, 1981,
Ronald Wilson Reagan enter the white house with a seemingly crazy idea to
disable the nuclear arsenal of their arch enemy, the Soviet union,
his goal to render the threat, the idea of mutually assured destruction,
totally obsolete.
So Ronald Reagan wanted to write off decades of military strategy.
I call upon the scientific community in our country.
Those who gave us nuclear weapons to turn their great talents now to the cause
of mankind and world peace to give us the means rendering these.
Nuclear weapons in an obsolete.
And the question,
the big question is how on earth did the then president of United States hope to
turn all of the Soviet nuclear power and to just a bunch of harmless old bricks?
Well, in order to answer that question, my friends,
I first have to ask you another question.
Does the term star Wars ring a bell and I'm not talking about three great movies
and six terrible ones
On the 23rd of March, 1983, Ronald Reagan introduced the SDI,
the strategic defense initiative, better known as the star Wars initiative.
Their goal was to build a system both on earth and in space capable of
dismantling and annihilating, any attempt a Soviet nuclear attack,
but wait a minute, this sounds simple, but how exactly do you do it?
The truth is that in spite of everything at the beginning,
there was really no clear idea of how to go about this.
The scientists and experts put forward many different possibilities all the way
from laser weapons installed on the ground or in space to different types of
missiles and tracking systems. However,
later on what they seem to be betting on, because all of this as a top secret,
highly confidential matter was developed.
Small metals launched from space itself, known as brilliant.
Pebbles.
And this way Reagan's idea was to make the Soviet nuclear military system
obsolete by leaving the USSR totally exposed in offensive and defensive matters,
but was Regan bluffing, or does he really think this was all possible? Well,
the truth is that it really doesn't matter all that much.
The point was that the Soviet union believed,
and it seemed to all this STI star Wars stuff,
worried them a lot less than up.
The Soviet union believed that the great technological potential of the United
States had scored again and treated Reagan statement as a real threat and a
totally Dobrynin Soviet ambassador to the U S from 1962 to
1986, maybe we should just stop being afraid of SDI.
Of course we can't simply disregard this dangerous program,
but we should overcome our obsession with it.
They're banking on the USSR fear of SDI in moral economic, political,
and military terms.
They're pursuing this program to wear us out orbit in a speech
to the Politburo in March, 1986.
Here. The truth is that in the Kremlin,
they were starting to become obsessed with this whole star Wars thing. It went,
I felt like this. I mean, okay, what are you going to just bluffing?
And he does not have the technology at all, but okay. On the other hand,
what if they do have the technology that would be the end of the cold war?
So the fact is that the Soviets who were beginning to feel cornered did not
stand idly by, and instead they raised the stakes in 19 seven,
the Soviets launched the military spacecraft Polybius from the back of nor
Cosmodrome.
This spacecraft was equipped with a scaffold laser system and a cast iron
missile system,
their goal to bring down Reagan's SDI spaceship by putting their own mega weapon
into orbits.
What was the result though? They didn't succeed into putting it into orbit.
The ship was shattered in the blink of an eye. And in this way,
the star Wars strategy became an unprecedented bargaining chip for the Reagan
administration.
No probiotic trust, but verify.
No doubt about it. Every time Reagan and Gorbachev sat down,
star Wars always came up at the Geneva bilateral summer of 1985 at the
Razorbacks.
I'm like I'm 1986 and the Washington summit of 1987 and the Moscow summit of
1988.
The strategic defense initiative in fact proved to be the ultimate bargaining
chip. And we played it for all. It was worth George Schultz,
the U S secretary of state under Ronald Reagan.
But then in the 1990s with the collapse of the Soviet union star Wars seemed to
be redundant. And although the program was never formally canceled,
its budget was drastically reduced after the fall of the USSR.
So then is that it is the cold war over is the concept of space as a
battlefield, dead and buried. Do I never get a laser gun? Well,
not at all because there is still much more because you see, in January, 2001,
we would see a new turning point in terms of space policy that month,
Donald Rumsfeld, future secretary of defense and the new George W.
Bush administration alerted Congress from an independent commission.
He cheered to a new eminent danger.
The United States was on the verge of a new peril Harbor,
but it was a parallel Harbor and space. Listen to.
The space forces.
According to the latest available data from the union of concerned scientists,
United States has at the time of making this video 1,327 operational
satellites and orbits of which approximately 30% belong to the government or the
military, no other country has so many satellites to give you an idea.
According to existing estimates,
Russia has their own 169 and China 363.
And the influence of these American satellites on our daily lives is
astronomical. Get it. There is barely go date, but we don't use one.
When you ask for an Uber and it tells you when it has arrived,
when you travel by plane, when you make a transfer through your bank's website,
it's on and on and on. But as you might be able to imagine,
this whole setup is not just to provide conveniences for the civilian world.
And the military field satellites have become a key to communications
navigation, reconnaissance metal detection, target setting,
to be clear the Wars of the present and the future are already being fought from
space.
Thus.
As the Rumsfeld commission pointed out in 2001,
when it warned about a potential peril Harbor scenario in space,
I would look like a coordinated attack on us, military satellites,
which would render the most powerful army on earth blamed and an operative,
how would they control their drones?
How would they know what was happening in a location before they set foot on the
ground? How would the communicate with the trip?
[Inaudible].
Basically the same concept of star Wars that once alleviated the fear of the
enemy in times past is today very, very worrying to the North American giant.
And that fear is not for nothing in recent years, non allied countries,
such as China assured themselves capable of destroying satellites with missiles
without breaking.
[Inaudible].
Act in 2007 and a demonstration of force by Beijing,
the Chinese giant destroyed one of its own weather satellites, the fan Gwyn,
one seat with a medium range missile, the SC one name,
a muscle that although launched without an explosive charge at chief,
the destruction of the satellite by simply colliding with it. And here's a fun.
And also depressing fact,
this controlled collision generated more than 3000 fragments,
but today orbit the earth in the form of space junk.
There are no records of any space event that has generated as much DeBry as this
operation.
And this is important because due to the speed with which they circulate in
space,
even the smallest particles can be very dangerous for functioning satellites,
space stations or rocks.
Yes.
But it didn't stop there. In 2013,
China launched a new anti-satellite weapon and to space this time much further
away at reach some 18,600 miles a week approaching and
space terms,
at least us satellites that were 22,000 miles away from the earth on that
occasion, China claimed that it was just a scientific experiment,
nothing to be concerned about.
But today we knew that what China did that day was basically a performance
test of its new weapon. The dog coming to a grantor space, myself,
or the ability to reach high earth orbits that is placing an object more than
20,000 miles away.
All these events made Rumsfeld's words of warning rezoned in the white house,
a space parallel Harbor,
precisely because of this at the end of 2014 as Douglas lavaro deputy assistant,
secretary of defense for space policy tells us Barack Obama gave the order to
incorporate a lane item into the budget to resume research and this field of
space.
Great.
My friend's a visual politic at this point. The question is, what about Moscow?
Did Putin just stand by and watch Zhang pangs China prepare for a possible space
war? No, no, of course not. No, not that's all
In 2017 with Trump already in the white house,
the Russian Federation launched a rocket like pay attention here.
And from that rocket,
a satellite came out and from that satellite two more came out and the military
community, this device came to be nicknamed the Russian nesting satellites.
Yeah. Just like those cute little wooden dolls. Well,
these satellites began to make maneuvers that allowed them to change orbits with
all the unpredictability and shakiness that, that entails.
And that's not all on a separate occasion.
Another Russian satellite followed several us and Alex satellites.
Of course you don't have to be Einstein to imagine that if your goal is to be
able to destroy satellites,
having the technology to carry out that goal is a pretty important step.
[Inaudible].
And the land of rock and roll Apple pie and terrible beer.
How have they dealt with all these developments? Well,
although in the United States,
everything related to space has historically been channeled through the air
force in August of 2019,
Trump reactivated Reagan's former us space command and pay attention because the
reactivation of this division was only the first step later that year,
Trump decreed the creation of the U S S F the United States space force with
fewer than 20,000 men, this new branch of the army dressed by the way,
and camouflage uniform,
because allegedly the personnel comprising the space forces in spite of their
name are on the ground.
It's in charge of chaining in the face of possible adverse scenarios related to
satellites. I don't know. I imagine for example,
a command is about to deploy, to carry out a special mission.
And at that moment,
the satellite they are communicating with mysteriously fails at that point,
a division of the U S S F comes into action and would reassign a new satellite
to the command. In addition, if the satellite fails as a result of an attack,
they will study how to disable or if necessary destroy the external agents
that said it must be stated that there's currently no clear and agreed upon
version of what the U S S F should be.
It seems that the most accepted version would be of a coast guard Lake style
space force. If you can imagine such a thing,
responsible for ensuring as much as possible,
a safe space environment for us and allied commercial satellites for their
part throughout all of these developments,
China and Russia have played a strong negotiating Trump card.
If you don't want us to install weapons in space,
let's make an agreement that we all sign up to. But on this occasion,
the responsibility United States has been a categorical. No,
the Americans say that they are not sure that they can verify that the agreement
is being fulfilled and that furthermore,
this would not prevent the accumulation of S 80 devices on the ground ready to
be launched into space. But what do you all think if it were up to you,
would you say in such an agreement trusting the other countries,
or would you use all available resources to be the first to achieve
technological superiority and will help me get a laser done?
Leave your answers in the comments below.
So we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit, like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos here on visual politics.
Don't forget also to check out our friends on the reconsider media podcast,
they provided you the vocals on this episode that were not my dulcet tunes.
Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
I want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice.
Come check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you
find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play,
or your favorite podcast. [inaudible].